welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madnesses trailer is a
cryptic freak show that continues to
tease new clues to this movie's mystery
plot and the way it's gonna bridge the
mcu multiverse together and even more
overlooked details have emerged from
this footage that we must discuss
simultaneously extending this film's
horizons to the sorcery of one division
and the timeline insanity of loki and
from all this we may now understand
strange's relationship with wanda
maximoff and with his goth table self
and for my preliminary analysis of this
multiverse of madness trailer be sure to
check out my no way home post credit
scene video in the follow-up breakdown
in the trailer when it dropped on
youtube but i don't talk about something
in this video because i already covered
him one of those okay the first new
detail to emerge was the shot of wanda
early in the trailer conjuring red chaos
magic in her palm but in the background
there is a glowing orange shape that
looks a lot like a time door of the time
variance authority from loki remember
the tva was actually created to do the
bidding of he who remains a variant of
kang in his vast plan to prune the
timeline so that it all goes according
to the script that he can pose for it
probably a script that best serves
himself and his council of kangs one of
whom takes his place as a more public
face of the tba in the season finale if
this is a time door for the tva to cross
over into multiverse of madness is both
perfect but also a bit surprising sam
raimi's imagery for this film steers
more into supernatural horror than to
the retro douglas adams zean sci-fi
production design of loki that series
relationship with magic was limited
setting the tva in a kind of no magic
zone but if you think about it in order
for that magic neutralization to
function there must also be some even
more powerful magic that fuels the tva
kind of like wanda and egg of those no
magic runes that they used as boundaries
in one division this anti-magic magic
could come from kang himself a kind of
magic we have yet to learn about could
be an mcu version of coronal energy
which in the comics was the energy that
the timekeepers were constructed to be
batteries of and stems from the
countless variances to the time stream
by the infinite number of kangs meddling
within it now i know i sound obsessive
right now but it's because if i ever
like miss a detail or get a theory wrong
i start pulling my hair out which is
totally the wrong way to go because some
guys just lose their hair naturally it's
super stressful for the guys i know
going through it it's one of those parts
of aging that can make you feel older
when you realize your co-worker was born
when you were in high school two out of
three guys will experience some form of
nail pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 but with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or pharmacy
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go to a doctor's office keeps as a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality easily subscribe to keeps and
get refill reminders so you'll never run
low on the products you need to take
care of your hair hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars but between
the time lords of loki and the sorcery
conjurers of doctor strange and
wandavision we're really left with some
unanswered questions about the exact
power hierarchy of these figures in the
mcu like does kang supersede the
sorcerer's supreme or the ancient one
how do the watcher or the celestials fit
into this i think this film could
finally start to give us some answers on
that i like to imagine all these baldies
have a seat at a cosmic table as checks
and bounces for each other gossiping
about each other while others are like
what did you say about me and then
kang's like nothing nothing nothing
but anyway a time door in this movie
could mean a cameo by loki or sylvie
mobius b 15 red slayer hell anyone from
that corner of the cosmos or a cameo by
jonathan majors as another kang variant
like majors is scheduled to return in
quantum mania but if we are looking at
the mcu's multiverse collision crisis in
this movie the way loki and sylvia left
things in the citadel or we should say
the way this kang variant manipulated
them to destabilize the multiverse so a
more hostile variant could take charge
perfectly corresponds to the crisis of
this film we're just seeing it from
doctor strange's front of this war where
the chaos takes a darker more
slitheringy form we just have yet to see
if this madness is something kang caused
and premeditated or as i believe it was
an inevitable absolute point the end
result of strange's various
manipulations of time and reality over
the years and people like kang saw that
coming and jumped on this opportunity to
strike whether or not this even is a
time door one undeniable easter egg that
you might have missed from this trailer
comes in this shot of strange conjuring
red sorcery in that alternate sanctum
where he later faces a darker variant of
himself and if you look closely at
strange's feet he is conjuring those red
orbs from the dark hold or from a dark
hold remember the dark old is marvel's
book of the dam that first appeared in
wanovision first in agatha's possession
from which she read those runes that the
scarlet witch's powers were destined to
surpass those of the sorcerer's supreme
technically wong at the moment and this
book ended that series in wanda's
possession as she used it to search the
multiverse for a reality with her sons
in it so in this trailer when doctor
strange says that he doesn't care about
west view it's not a meta line saying
the events of wanovision won't matter to
this film because the fact that wanda
ended that arc with the darkhold is
going to be hugely important that is
probably why strange is coming to wanda
in this moment so what is strange now
doing here with the darkhold well those
red orbs tethered together we call the
red orbs that orbited wanda in her
astral form in that final scene each one
possibly representing a different world
within the multiverse but here as the
orb spread out the one in the lower left
corner seems to be dividing into another
world like cells undergoing cellular
mitosis so now the darkhold could be
strange's one way of getting a
bird's-eye view of the multiverse and
investigating what caused its rapid
expansion in addition to the sanctum
being the place that he meets his darker
self this may also be the sanctum that
strange ascends the stairs of because
notice how in that opening shot the
staircase railings are different than
the ones we've seen before there are
also new statues flanking the base of
the steps and a new chandelier hangs
over the doorway so this is not
strange's new york sanctum that we've
seen in no way home this is an alternate
reality sanctum and in addition to the
wall on the right being blown open to a
stormy beach you can also see a vast
opening to the outdoors on the left this
whole sanctum is strewn on the shore
like a shipwreck so did wanda give
strange the darkhold or did he take it
by force or did he just totally fail
because we never see the two of them
together other than their chat and that
orchard and even that ends with wandis
aggressive
you say to strange when he brought up
the multiverse otherwise this whole
trailer is just that shot of her firing
up her palm cannons karmartash coming
under attack and then scarlet witch
conducting her seance and if you look
closely at that floor this is totally
the camaraderie courtyard the pattern on
the floor is the same as the other shots
we see of that battle in this location
it could be wanda behind those attacks
on comtaj as she usurps power there
defacing these sacred grounds with her
creepy serenity by jan collection now we
pointed out how wanda's fingertips are
black here like agatha's fingers became
when she used dark magic against wanda
in that final episode and in this case a
sign that dark forces have also
overtaken wanda now we should also note
that her scarlet witch wardrobe has
evolved from when we last saw it in one
division her arms and shoulders are now
fully covered and her chest now has an
inky black v section so i think we are
now seeing a conqueror scarlet witch
refusing to let strange take the book
that she feels she earned rightly and
that could be what leads doctor strange
to this alternate sanctum in another
reality in which his goth table
doppelganger in this universe collects
the most evil antiquities he can get his
hands on including this version of the
darkhold a darkhold of this reality
which strange needs to track wanda
across the multiverse you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newarkstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
for always watching our goddess scarlet
witch
[Music]
you